der supreme court ist die dritte gewalt
in den usa explizit in der verfassung
festgeschrieben wie viele richter es
sein sollen oder welche qualifikationen
sie brauchen steht aber nicht seit mehr
als 150 jahren entscheiden insgesamt
neun richterin
sie werden durch den aktuellen us
präsidenten ernannt vom us-senat im
justizausschuss überprüft und
schließlich bestätigt im amtsvenn sie
laut verfassung so lange wie ihre
amtsführung einwandfrei ist
im prinzip ist sie freiwillig in pension
gehen oder zurücktreten oft aber ein
leben lang
das kann aber unter umständen bei jungen
richterinnen eine jahrzehntelange
aufgabe werden die richterinnen haben
mit ihren urteilen das letzte wort bei
grundsatzfragen beispielsweise über
abtreibung die ehe für alle einwanderung
oder diskriminierung
keiner kann ihre entscheidung noch
einmal kippen auch nicht der präsident
als etwa entschieden wurde dass die
rassentrennung an schulen gegen die
verfassung verstößt war es das ende
getrennte schulen viel macht also in den
händen von neuen richterinnen das aber
mit voller absicht die entscheidung der
richter müssen nicht einstimmig
getroffen werden es reicht eine einfache
mehrheit sofern mindestens sechs richter
an der abstimmung teilnehmen momentan
gelten fünf richter als eher konservativ
und drei als eher liberal
die neubesetzung von embedded würde die
mehrheit der konservativen richter
festigen und damit die rechtsprechung
der usa durch den supreme court viele
jahre prägen